- I don't think it's gonna taste weird.
But I don't know how I'm
gonna get the thought
of like a thousand crickets
screaming out of my mind.
(upbeat rock music)
- Like we'rte gonna run
out of regular protein?
- Yes.
- Like one day we're gonna run around--
- That might happen.
- [Woman] In trees.
- I'm not a religious man but I am
praying it tastes like chocolate.
- Do they, like, let 'em bleed out
before they blend them?
- [Man] Urgh!
- Or do they blend them,
like, with everything intact?
- And then here it comes.
- That looks so gross.
- You're not gonna show me a cricket
while I eat the crickets are you?
(ominous music)
- Oh boy.
- Wait, wait, you are aren't you?
- Oh my God.
- Yeww urgh!
Why??
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
- Dara would eat that,
for like, five bucks.
- No I wouldn't!!
- (laughs) Yeah you would.
- Like 10 bucks!
- Look at them, they're
like, don't eat my friends!
- Oh my God, don't give them voices.
- Just, just tastes like chocolate.
Just tastes like chocolate.
- Tastes good.
- [Woman] What?!
- There's Oreo in there
but I just bit something
that had a little
(imitates popping noise),
like a little pop to it.
- Do you feel like this
is at all affecting
your enjoyment of this?
- It did for a second but now
I'm just gonna have some more.
- If you had just brought me an Oreo shake
and said, "This is just an Oreo shake."
I'd say, "Thank you."
- But now that we're
looking, we're doing this,
we have the knowledge of it right there.
Why would you do that?
- Ignorance is bliss in this situation.
- I feel sorry I ate
your brothers or sisters.
- I don't care.
- (laughs) Oh my!
- [Man] Tastes good.
- I know it is super
popular in other countries.
- I'm just glad that they
shredded it pretty well.
Right?
- I got another head.
- Oh, okay.
- When we start to run
out of water and stuff
and like we start to
enter some Mad Max (beep).
It'll get into the crickets.
I think that like bugs
will be the super-protein
when we're just dead here, you know?
Not to be dark but--
- Damn, you went there.